doit-on interdire la chirurgie
esthétique pour les moins de 25 ans il
n'y a que des noms un seul oui on va le
garder pour un peu plus tard charlotte
toi tu dis non non non et encore non
parce que faut pas oublier qu'il ya des
gens qui ont de réelles complexes qui
sont pas forcément liés aux réseaux etc
et ça les empêche de vivre ils sont
pêche de vie vraiment et ils vont pas
attendre 25 ans pour commencer à vivre
donc non faut pas interdire pour faire
de la sensibilisation faut expliquer aux
jeunes que les nanas de télé réalité ne
représente pas les standards de beauté
il faut aussi expliquer que voilà les
réseaux c'est que lui fait l'écart en
faillite une pour les photos les filtres
sur l'historien stoneham etc il faut
aussi je pense fort mais les chirurgiens
avoir un meilleur code moral donc les
rendre plus raisonnable lors dire que
voilà au kenya le garde l'argent mais si
jamais il ya une cliente qui a une
demande trop exagéré voire dangereuse
savoir dire non et si jamais on n'en
peut plus et qu'on ne veut vraiment
passer sous le bistouri trouver le bon
chirurgien a chargeant raisonnable qui
saura faire bien des adresses des
données pertinentes
de l'opération de chirurgie c'est ce qui
s'appelle
sur le fait que j'aie téléchargé je n'ai
jamais fait de chirurgie pas de lamu ne
m'en veuillez pas tabou si je voulais un
bon moment je te
fais des pommettes j'ai fini pollution
j'ai pas honte de le dire on est haut et
faudrait grandit on en 2022
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
suisse a réussi cet usage de la
chirurgie esthétique bien sûr après pour
choisir son chirurgien si tu veux pas
c'est toujours pareil mais c'est comme
quand on a mis nouveau garage sis à
movie garagiste bah oui un problème
concernant les dérives dans la question
tu l'as fait avec 45 ans l'avait pas 25
ans à 23 ça n'existait pas on n'est pas
trop dur il faut pas tout mélanger la
charge et elle peut être réparatrice
elle peut répondre à des besoins de
santé ou à des complexes en revanche il
faut combattre la banalisation oui de
l'air chargé c'était qui devient
finalement une activité commerciale en
gros de botox achetée une offerte bah
oui c'est vrai et c'est oh mais on
devrait mettre je sais pas arrêté les
promos que les autorités fassent des
choses justes pour protéger les nôtres
et les plus jeunes tu as tu dis ça parce
que tu payes pas des opérations comme
bah oui
oui franc autour de la table c'est celui
de juliette oui alors c'est un oui
vraiment très franc et or pour le coup
je veux commencer par mettre mon veto en
disant que je ne parle évidemment pas
des personnes des jeunes personnes qui
ont un nez extrêmement proéminent où les
dents du fond qui mène avec celle du
devant fin non je parle vraiment de
celle qu voilà qui ont commencé par
juste refaire un nez qui ont fait voilà
alors déjà mois d'une part j'ai trois
filles je trouve que vers 16 17 ans les
parents qui autorisent leurs enfants à
faire ça c'est criminel pour moi en plus
le chirurgien qui fait ça et criminel
c'est à dire que ces filles là il y en a
aucune somme toute je me semble qu'ils
avaient vraiment un physique atypique où
un regard d'amour sur lequel on pouvait
se moquer donc c'est vraiment voilà ces
légères ça commence à prendre ne peut
plus arrêter effectivement elles
seraient elles se ressemblent toutes moi
ma fille elle me demande ça je vais
commencer déjà par lui dire va voir un
psy ça c'est s'accepter soi-même d'abord
on essaye de ont fait un travail sur soi
même
pas avoir besoin d'eux
je mange un méchant c'est votre fille
vous demande vous dit j'ai envie de
faire la chirurgie esthétique pour me
gonfler les lèvres ou pour autre chose
vas-y matinée je n'irai pas je ne
citerai pas le faire mais ces valeurs
c'est son choix la vingtaine ont les
majeures en artois 3,4 qu'elle veut soit
prochainement une échelle le colis
complexion là on parle pas de complexe
je pense qu'on la vraie question à se
poser pour ses jeunes fils et à qui
elles veulent plaire
à qui elles ont envie de toi tu penses
que le plus grand nombre d hommes qui
nous regardent ce soir aime ce genre de
femme oui
ce genre de femme moi j'aime tout est
faux
[Applaudissements]
et
l'essentiel c'est de se plaire alors
certains messages un peu miss france
mais ça que c'est de se plaire à soi
même et elle même c'est toi qui validait
rouge tu te fais pas du tout je crois
pas je pense qu'elles sont standardisés
et qu'elle sait comment je vais pouvoir
faire de l'argent par les réalités c'est
ressembler et glauque et apporté des
outils mais en fait si stéréotypes là
les corps aussi qui se transforme ces
décors qui sont inatteignables c'est à
dire le corps par exemple de nabila ça
reste un exemple nabila je pense qu'il y
avait à la base des prédispositions je
pense qu'elle a un métabolisme bon qui
est plutôt sympa mais là cette taille
ultra fine il faut dire aux jeunes
filles qu'on leur enlève des côtes en
fait aux homos au nanar avec lille dont
bien sûr bien sûr tu peux pas avoir une
taille ultra fines avec des fêtes donc
voilà tout ça c'est sa part des
kardashian ou bien méchant chaque fameux
quart des chutes parle de se former des
injections des injections massives
d'acide hyaluronique dans l'espèce cv
regarde trop de ça les regarde on se
retrouve pendant des semaines a pas
pouvoir s'asseoir elle se retrouve dès
que possible opération non mais sur
trois et septicémie je sais pas si tu as
vu il ya deux cars mort il ya deux cas
la règle et non jetons à vie de papa sur
la question alors moi alors moi des gens
me dire pourquoi 25 ans déjà alors moi
je suis je suis pas pour interdire à 25
ans mais moi je pense par contre que
mineur déjà ça me dérange car car
j'avais souvenir ni les mineurs ne
peuvent pas avoir recours à la chirurgie
esthétique sans autorisation bas et ça
m'est déjà mais juste là déjà alors sauf
6 du réparatrice à on est d'accord et
chirurgie réparatrice entièrement
d'accord seule chose par contre moi je
me dis que à partir de 18 ans il ya des
femmes qui souffrent et à partir du
moment où ça l'a fait souffrir elle par
contre là je rejoins totalement le
discours de sophie sur l'acceptation de
soi faut que ça soit vraiment dans une
optique de se plaire à soi même et pas
de me dire à quelqu'un ou de vouloir
ressembler à quelqu'un d'autre parce que
c'est là c'est clairement le problème
surtout que le petit copain de malartic
au part actuelle il va aimer les gros
seins et
commerciaux parce que la société dans
laquelle on évolue les jeunes filles
d'aujourd'hui et si vous nous regardez
ce soir vous n'êtes pas en mesure de
savoir si c'est à vous que ça plaît
aussi c'est pour plaire à la société à
dire que tous les jours vous êtes sur
instagram à mettre des filtres qui vous
des formes la bouche si vous des formes
les pommettes de vous rapproche des yeux
et qui vous donne un physique
apparemment idéal mais qui ne met
absolument pas les filtres sur instagram
c'est l'un des plus gros fléau oui pour
les je suis aujourd'hui qu'ils pensent
que c'est un sac elles doivent
ressembler que si elles n'ont pas leurs
filtres smap ou instagram sur le visage
sombre elles sont moches ces
ex-travailleurs tendance à ses jours et
moi je pense aussi que essentiellement
aussi psychologiquement est-ce que moi
la première est que je pense vous tous
ici présents c'est est ce qu'on pense la
même chose à 18 ans caca40 c'est à dire
que moi j'avais absolument pas le même
corps à 18 ans admet matin même à 25 ans
effectivement adam à 40 et pour le coup
et si j'avais changé quelque chose chez
moi par exemple moi mon sa haine mais
grosse narines enfin voilà j'aurais pu
faire quelque chose j'ai fait le choix
de ne pas le faire parce qu'en plus je
ne pense plus du tout pareil que quand
j'avais 18 ou 20 ans mais parce que mon
travail à la
coban école que les oreilles décollées
corps est passé entre 3 10 fermes et les
fruits heureusement
qu'ils sont complètement con prince et
de ses combats les plus loin dans le
débat on vous a préparé un petit best-of
des chirurgies esthétiques les plus
extrêmes on regarde de quoi on parle on
commence avec ce phénomène
ce sont eux qui veulent ressembler à la
poupée barbie barbie et ça c'est ce dont
parlait sophie c'est l'écho et
mensurations elle a permis dans les
seins mais en fait ça en fait là ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'elle n'a plus de
coach c'est à dire qu' il reste deux
côtes vous le voyez est empli de boeuf
façon et on va normalement il y en a
cinq donc on est on a enlevé trois
quarts ça c'est moi je me perds on les a
mis dans la boîte est visé c'est pas
barbis assez dormi après le vaccin c'est
pas sympa barbie
on enchaîne avec une émission de
relooking aux états unis vous allez voir
des américains ne font pas dans la
dentelle on regarde la vidéo
[Applaudissements]
quelle différence
voici pourquoi blaikie à un tel sourire
on lui a reconstruit la lèvre et le
n'est ni un dentier partiel inférieur et
supérieur blanchit les dents et posé
huit facettes en céramique lors d'une
deuxième opération elle a eu d un plan
au sein une réduction du ventre
l'élimination de varices une liposuccion
du cou et des cuisses de défigurer et
les devenu éclatante
aller à seignosse un nouvel lèvres comme
tu vas acheter une baguette mais est ce
qu'ils aient légion ah ben c'est
l'esthétique c'était la partie au
premier rendez vous très psychologique
sur les motivations j'ai l'impression
que ça c'était un petit peu pas du tout
non parce que c'est devenu un commerce
et alors que ces deux-là millions il ya
beaucoup de géorgiens le meilleur
portier géorgien ils refusent parfois
certaines opérations dimanche est
nécessaire
je ne côtoie personnes de mon entourage
enfin dans ma petite campagne qui s'est
fait refaire quoi que ce soit parce que
manque de moyens
ça m'embêterait d'avoir un jour ma fille
en face de moi à table admettons et je
la regardais unibal tu me sourit août
envie de faire caca je vois là sa
plus une expression d'amour c'est raté
aussi non je ne dis pas que c'est raté
ce serait mentir mais après c dans
l'extrême salsa restent elles restent
figées alors les dons effectivement
d'accord mais après on peut arranger
avec un maquillage et une coiffure sans
aller à l'extrême comme ça là voilà est
saisie qu'elle fasse son mari après bah
oui c'est toujours le même échange de
marie parler elle change de marie force
parce que le mari lui la thèse sérieuse
a déjà bien au départ bah oui
ok argentine les candidates de télé
réalité accro à la chirurgie esthétique
avec le témoignage de miles and
candidate des marseillais on regarde il
ya quelques années quand les filtres ont
commencé à sortir sur instagram je ne me
maquille et qu'avec qu'à travers les
filtres en tête et je me maquille et
donc j'étais dans un déni complet
j'étais persuadé de ressembler à ça moi
je n'avais plus conscience de décrire
mon visage ça c'est moi quand je les
fais toutes mes opérations c'est mon
objectif dit qu'est ce que tu as changé
j'ai fait le nez et là il est tout neuf
il a dû jour je vous présente s'appelle
richard j'ai fait les seins j'ai fait du
botox ensuite j'ai fait les lèvres donc
j'ai fait quatre fois les injections
j'ai envie de ça
ça c'est inquiétant quand même c'est pas
apprécié c'est beau c'est elle se sent
épanoui avec son équipe a tué son beau
frère
de l'ex a besoin de son métier aussi
sans doute ça ne vient pas d'elle même
c'est pas elle qui un jour s'est
réveillé en disant voilà à quoi je veux
ressembler elle explique très bien
d'ailleurs et qu'elle ne se regardaient
plus qu'à travers son téléphone et à
travers son filtre qu'elle n'avait plus
conscience des traits de son visage et
qualité dans un déni complet ça pour moi
extrêmement dangereux un filtre aurait
eu comme ça a pu rendre ce qu'elle a
comme modèle une poupée fictives c'est
même plus un humain ce mode est une
poupée est fictif c'est à dire qu'avec
complètement dans un autre monde elle
est complètement matrix et par tout ça
et même quand elle dit oui mon nouveau
né il a dix jours on dirait qu'elle
parle d'une assiette et une allemande--
s'était adjugé le dialogue jours force
est horrible c'est voilà et elle
banalise a changé esthétique comme on va
chez boulanger comme la trêve
ça c'est trop c'est too much c'est
vraiment too much il ya dix ans encore
quand on ne faisait des études de
médecine vaffier en médecine en ce
moment il ya dix ans et deux personnes
voulaient faire chirurgie esthétique
maintenant c'est l'un des premiers
postes savez c'est en fonction du
classement à la fin de l année premiers
pas ce qui est demandé maintenant c'est
plutôt tabou il m'a tendu
une fan de kim kardashian qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure qui a dépensé 120 mille
euros pour lui ressembler on regarde
j'adore qui ne l'aiment tellement j'ai
toujours admiré les femmes fortes
racontez nous les opérations que vous
avez eu jusqu'à maintenant donc j'ai
fait des injections dans les lèvres
évidemment j'ai fait du botox des
injections aux pommettes j'ai fait des
injections au menton pour mieux définir
ma mâchoire et j'ai fait tatouer mes
sources et
voilà c'est génial à la piscine et
flotte
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que ça à côté de ça
finalement on se permet de juger toutes
ces personnes mais finalement elles font
de mal acquis
il ya des chirurgiens qui arrêtent qui
acceptent encore un parent qui va lui
des gens là on arrête on arrête tu
d'argent te mettre en danger et entrave
voilà
et ça donne des gens dans ce débat là et
qu'ils ne se rendent même pas compte
qu'ils sont malades du coup c'est un
média un grand il ya surtout il ya un
grand mal être en fait ce que je vois
c'est ça qu'il faut soigner moi j'ai pas
de lui moi j'ai trois garçons mais je
peux imaginer effectivement quand on a
des filles de 15 ans 16 ans qui veulent
commencer à modifier des choses on se
demande effectivement si on a bien fait
notre travail de parents si on leur a
bien donné confiance et que ça et tant
mieux je suis content de ne pas avoir de
fille pour ça parce que je me dis quelle
angoisse quoi quand je les
images à la france le faux quand je
pense c'est lolo ferrari
comme entre une ferrari et lolo ferrari
ne saute pas forcément aux yeux sauf
pour les connaisseurs de la croisée je
crois qu'ils ont des gabarits voyez le
même derrière le même devant mais aussi
d'autres voitures la femme aux plus gros
seins de rock devient l'emblème d'objets
qui porteront son nom car on sait quand
une ferrari lolo ferrari se
commercialisent déjà avec un disque
gonflé airbags generation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est choquant je suis pas je suis
pas assez et sert de toute évidence mais
je me demande si on n'a pas des
problèmes de dos après fin des
saisies dans l'eau sans aucun temps
c'était une vraie star à l'époque une
station nationale donc voilà cette
raison sf1 franchement moi me fait plus
mal au ventre mal au coeur elle doit
être tellement fall devait être
tellement mal dans sa peau pour en
arriver là c'est que tu es bien si c'est
possible un pur est morte il
interdire la chirurgie esthétique aux
moins de 25 ans ce n'est pas si simple
qu'il faille réguler la pratique de la
chirurgie esthétique oui qu'il fallait
faire attention au bon ou au mauvais
chirurgien bien sûr